I love this it's from end wokeness they
say Walgreens in Chicago unveils
anti-theft store in response to
shoplifting there are only two aisles in
the entire store everything else needs
to be ordered at a virtual kiosk look at
this you walk in and there's virtual
kiosks where it says shop our full
selection you can't actually touch any
of the products so there's pickup
there's iPads I guess where you can
order what you want then someone brings
it to you that's how bad things are
getting that sounds like so hateful
about those Walgreens where is franchise
owners Chicago
yeah in in San Francisco they were
putting everything behind glass locked
uh uh cabinets well that's what happens
when you decriminalize theft under 900
yes crazy it's funny it's funny how we
talked about that when they did it they
say anything under a thousand dollars
won't be will be decriminalized and
we're like oh this is going to result in
lots of shoplifting and then what
happens videos of people shoving things
into garbage bags yeah stores every
retail stores leaving I think Whole
Foods left Target left too didn't they
maybe not enough
a bunch of people isn't it hilarious
that the media loses their mind when
people decide not to shop at Target but
when people actively steal in droves
from other chains it's totally fine or
it's not worthy of our attention it's
like people don't shop at Target they're
like this is civilizational collapse and
then in San Francisco people are just
walking out of the store with 800 worth
of crap and not getting in trouble for
it
normal that's how it should be for
Target the internal memo that was sent
out by corporate I think Benny Johnson
leaked it but the internal memo
basically Brands what was happening to
Target as like a corporate January 6th
January
um a couple days ago three days ago
years ago yeah and they basically
branded us to corporate January 6th
they're like we're at risk please move
all the gay displays somewhere else to
the back of the store because their
employees their employees were at risk
because of the rainbow displays and your
non-binary baby onesies but not when
people are shoplifting and burning down
the stores in 2020. also correct me if
I'm wrong but I don't think the problem
on January 6th that everyone was
clutching their pearls and freaking out
over was that conservatives weren't
going inside right like this is this is
literally people saying we're not going
to enter your building we're like this
is this is just like the time you
trespassed all over again trespass when
the cops were opening the doors for you
and I gotta like extrapolate this out to
the real estate market because I think
people are really sleeping on the
commercial real estate market this is
horrific for Commercial Business oh yeah
and and Commercial Real Estate like who
is going to be filling those vacancies
in San Francisco yeah you'd have to be
out of your mind let's add more to it
this is from yahoo.com Fortune all hell
is going to break loose property Titan
and Shark Tank star Barbara Corcoran
says Elon Musk is right about commercial
office space there you go Elon said it's
going to collapse and Corcoran said in
fact it's going to be a bloodbath
echoing the statements of Elon Musk as
commercial real estate is melting down
fast yeah nobody wants to be in a city
where people are pooping in front of
your store and then stealing your stuff
but think about this now now just
imagine for a moment this is just me
speculating who knows if this is the way
things go but here's a potential that
opens up here what if wealthy people who
are more connected to political leaders
and the kinds of laws that they
Implement get word ahead of time of the
fact that the Democrats are sick of
what's happening and are going to start
promoting tough on crime policies and
repealing these laws so now when the
real estate has hit rock bottom you buy
that property up new laws are
implemented where Law and Order is
actually upheld and that property value
goes way up I am very curious if they do
ever turn this around because they have
to in order to save these cities who's
going to end up holding all of the
property that's being devalued right now
I'll tell you the problem yes black
rocks black rocks in the Bible but I'll
tell you the big the big issue is
why would why would I want to buy the
dip you can tell me that why would I
want to locate in San Francisco right
because so so I hear you that we
wouldn't want to but if you're a venture
capitalist and you know politically
you're not I'm sure you lost I
understand yes yeah I'm saying dude
BlackRock will buy it up and the problem
is US knowing about it won't matter
because anybody who's aware of how the
Democrats operate is not going to buy it
yeah so it will tank the price then
you'll get big firms like BlackRock or
whoever else to buy it up and then they
own it and the government will buy it up
too like de Blasio was saying in New
York they're going to buy up these
buildings for pennies in the dollar
after their policies destroyed the
market yeah and turn them into public
housing what's really weird is that you
haven't seen much softening in pricing
even even with these incredible
vacancies and interest rates having more
than doubled on on conventional
mortgages so I I think that we haven't
seen the the real wreckage yet in the
pricing so I think people should be uh a
little bit hesitant about jumping in
feet first in the real estate so you
think that the real estate Market's
gonna tank uh not actually single
families and particularly in red States
like Florida I'm actually pretty bullish
on but I think that the blue states
where you've seen mass migrations of
people basically refugees like myself
and Josie last night I think that those
states are are in for a world of hurt
unless unless the FED pivots on their
interest rate hiking in which case maybe
look you can move out to a more rural
area where you can get a nice house with
some good land and buy some chickens
with their goofy little faces
yes you choose you choose you can live
in these cities those Marines we just
saw those Marines get get stomped out
and those kids are being charged and one
of them is being charged as an adult
Marines were like I guess I don't know
what the issue was a fight broke guy
they tried to stop it so the kids
started stomping on them you've got uh
the the the subway attacks in New York
people being pushed in front of trains
so I mean seriously if
we know the Democrats Play Dirty games
just gutting these cities empowering and
enriching themselves I'm not saying you
should completely leave but move to the
outskirts get to the suburbs my full
recommendation is get out of the cities
and if you can't because of your job or
your family get as far away from the
centers as possible where you can have
more land it makes me sad when people
want to give up on these cities they're
like I'm in New York City and I can't
leave you know my family's there my
child's there I can't leave New York
City and why would we give up on New
York City where I walk down the street
and your there's Francis Tavern which is
the tavern that George Washington was at
that is super cool I mean that's a big
part of our history in our country and
it makes me very sad to abandon you know
what our country was built on as long as
you're under Democratic like actual
democracy rule then you you can't New
York City was fantastic under Giuliani
he really cleaned that City up and this
is what I'm saying you're I think at
some point if they're interested in
turning these places around I think
there's a question of whether this is
just total collapse of these areas but I
see the possibility of what happened in
the past occurring where you do have
some tough on crime leader being elected
to power in these very blue cities and
states and they sort of turn these
cities around yeah it only has to happen
once in one city and that'll set a
precedent another one it is out of
control though and it's a lot of this
decriminalization too I was talking to
you guys before the show I have like a
crackhead spawn point outside of my
building but there's this one guy really
and there's this one guy I'm not making
this up he always is assaulting people
and threatening people with a cane and
every now and then he gets rested and
then he's back like a couple weeks later
doing the same thing
is to make someone disappear for three
days and then put them back in the same
spot there's a viral video where someone
is filming a tent in front of their
apartment or whatever and the guy's
waving a knife and stabbing the wall and
threatening people yeah they're like he
does this every day and they can't or
won't do anything about it and they're
so mean
you know usually ignore them but there
was one outside violent crackheads are
nice too well you know I I don't know
why I offer this one guy was like on the
verge of tears talking about how he was
hungry and so when I went into CVS I got
him a water and a sandwich and I go to
give it to him and he goes nah B I need
money not a sandwich
just nasty it's free food's free you go
behind a Wendy's at night and there's
Burgers you go buying a bagel shop at
noon and there's Bagels they don't need
food you can't take the food you gave
him he didn't take it no he said Nabi I
don't need that I need money not a
sandwich after he was screaming that he
was hungry yes he was like on the Virgin
tears and then by the time I came out he
uh wasn't hungry maybe he got fed you
don't know dude that's the problem with
humans man humans when they're in a good
place are pretty phenomenal creatures
but when they're not when they're crazy
when they're desperate when they're out
of their blazing high or drunk they're
like dangerous wild creatures with
opposable thumbs and smart enough to
think about how they can get you
tomorrow what's fascinating though is
that they're not desperate when it comes
to nutrition or nourishment like they
can get food that you don't see anybody
starving really in America so it's it's
a different it's a different problem
that we need to address because I mean
we're in if anything we're dealing with
overabundance we have so much at our at
our disposal but then you have these
homeless people that go down this path
of rampant drug addiction and even
though I'm a Libertarian I believe in
decriminalization I still don't think
that you should be enabling people to
just ruin the Public Square I mean
granted I don't think there should be a
Public Square but yeah foreign
versus the like towns people meet in a
certain area they call Public Schools
yeah you can still have a Public Square
but it just wouldn't be publicly owned I
just can I I want to make a point about
abundance really quickly here which is I
think that it's good to help people it's
good to try to offer them food I think
that's a very important thing to do uh
however most of the poverty in the
United States is a spiritual poverty
this is one thing that Mother Teresa
said we want to go feed people in other
worlds or in other parts of the world
but like we're not interested in giving
people the kind of sustenance they need
to have healthy lives to be members of a
community that's fulfilling to have
careers where they really feel like
they're making a difference and most
importantly really being part of a
religious structure and praising God
people not having these things causes
them to fall apart and we don't want to
acknowledge that because our philosophy
is if you just throw enough matter and
rearrange material real things enough
and you'll solve all of the problems and
it's not true it's not just matter
there's a spiritual component to us that
has to be said it's cultural cohesion
and that can exist in a lot of forms
some good some bad but we used to have
cultural cohesion in this country and
and now we don't I found with if I'm
walking past people on the street in the
city of the desperate people poor people
they'll be asking for money I I give
them a handshake and like eye contact
and they're so much happier than if I
give them a buck every time like the
dollar it's like I'm just a a piece of
crap that like facilitated more of their
misery but like actual contact seems as
what they're missing thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time